we have four quadrilaterals drawn right
over here and what I want us to think
about is looking at this green
quadrilateral here I want you to pause
the video and think about which of these
figures have the same area as the green
quadrilateral and so pause the video now
and think about that so I'm assuming you
gave a shot at it now let's think about
it and the way I'm going to think about
it is to really rearrange parts of this
green quadrilateral to make it look more
like maybe some of these other
quadrilaterals so for example if we were
to if we were to put a little dotted
line right over here and a dotted line
right over here we see that our green
our green shape is actually made up you
could imagine it being made up of a
triangle and then a rectangle and then
another triangle and what's interesting
about the two triangles is that they
represent the exact same area they
essentially both represent they each
represent half of this rectangle right
over here they represent half of this
rectangle down here let me do that in a
color they represent half of this entire
thing if I were to color it all I would
color it all in and if you have trouble
visualizing it imagine taking this top
part right over here and then flipping
it over it would look like this if you
flip it over this line right over here
it would look something like this it
would look something like this my best
attempt to draw it so take that top
section it would look something like
that and then move it down and then move
it down right over here to fit in here
and then this Plus this will fill in
this entire this entire region right
over here so that original green
trapezoid that we were looking at if you
take the top if you take that top part
out it essentially has the exact same
area as a rectangle as a rectangle that
has a height of four and a length and a
length of five so this right over here
has the exact same area as our trapezoid
and once again how did we do that
well we just took this top part flip it
over and relocated it down
here and we say hey we could actually
construct a rectangle that way so
essentially and and if you want to know
its area we could either just count the
squares here so we have let me do this
in a easier to see so we have 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20
of these unit squares right over here
and we know that there's an easier way
to do that we could have just multiplied
the height times the width we could have
just said look this thing is 1 2 3 4 hi
and 1 2 3 4 5 wide so 4 times 5 is going
to give us 20 of these unit squares so
that's the area in terms of unit squares
or square units of that original green
trapezoid now let's see which one of
these match that so this pink one right
over here if you don't even count this
bottom part if you were to just separate
this top part right over here this top
part is 4 high by 5 by 5 wide so just
this top part alone is 20 and then it
has this extra right over here so the
pink has a larger area than our original
green trapezoid the blue rectangle is 3
by 5 so it has a an area of 15 square
units now the red one is interesting it
is 1 2 3 4 hi and 1 2 3 4 5 long or 5
wide 4 times 5 is 20 squares and you can
validate that and so the red rectangle
has the same area as our original green
trapezoid